[موسيقى]
اذا في اخر تطورات المواجهات المسلحه
المستمره لليوم الثاني عشر في السودان
افاد مراسل الجزيره بتجدد المعارك بشتى
انواع الاسلحه بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع في محيط القصر الرئاسي واكد
مراسل جزيره عدويه
مركز الخرطوم كما اكد تجدد اطلاق النار
بين الجانبين شمال الخرطوم بحري تاتي هذه
تطورات بعد ساعات من خروج عدد من قله نظام
السوداني المعزول من السجن وتبادل طرفي
صراع المسؤوليه عن الحادثه ومع دخول الهدى
الرابعه يومها ثاني تتواصل عمليه اجلاء
الاجانب الى بلدانهم عبر مدينه بورسودان
ودول جوار السودان وقد نقلت شبكه ان عزم
واشنطن او نقلت عن واشنطن عزمها دراسه
خطته لارسال قوات امريكيه الى بورسودان
للمساعده في اجلاء الامريكيين
صورا مباشره تاتينا الان من الخرطوم وبزلت
طبعا الشبكات متواصله وما يدل عليها هذه
اعمده الدخان التي ما زالت الان تغطي سماء
المدينه وان كانت اخف من السابق وهذا يدل
على ان الاشتباكات متقطعه وليست
بمستوى الحد الذي كانت عليه سابقا ولكن
تبقى هذه الهدنه التي الان تدخل يومها
الثاني هشه مع تواصل الاشتباكات في مناحي
او في في مناطق شتى في الخرطوم خاصه حول
مقر القياده العامه ومحيط القصر الرئاسي